i think from here through the end of the
year at least the tentative idea it
could always change
is the tuesday night games at home are
gonna be the nights for the city connect
logan webb who is four and three with a
354 era a 24 year old
chris taylor who was the player of the
week in the national league
last week what a week he had
and he was doing it against a giant hit
three home runs in two games against the
giants
now he swings it misses on a changeup he
struck him out
julio urias on the mound for the dodgers
what the season he has had
so far 12 and three with a 363
era mike ostremski the banner next
on this one oh he hits a breaking ball
up the middle
on a bounce chris taylor's got it cody
bellinger will come to bat to start
the second in it one and done in san
francisco dodgers nothing giant snuggle
bellinger nursing a sore hamstring
missed the last two games because of it
3-2 pitch is in there strike three
caught in the inside corner
bellinger had started to go to first
base but that was right on the corner
the two-seam i'm sure looked like it was
going to be off the corner
and then it just kind of drifted back
and caught the inside at the knees
brilliant pitch
mckinney his numbers with the dodgers
two hits 12 at bats so far left-handed
hitter he's got power
eight homers and 195 official at bats
one and two pitch and a slider struck
him out looking
at the knees three strikeouts in two
innings three up and three down
rough coming up last of the second
nothing nothing rough a 263 hitter
he has been very difficult to keep out
of the lineup especially against
left-handed pitching
2-2 pitch perfectly play strike three
first of the game for elias one away in
the second
two down here's lamont wade junior
lamont wade jr coming off a career game
against the pirates on sunday with three
home runs
got him bottom falls out of a chain jump
we go to the third
it's the dodgers nothing giants nothing
two and two now
nothing nothing third inning right
beautiful night here in san francisco
the field is
all covered up with the dark shadows now
and there's a swinging strike three on a
slider
down around the knees austin slater had
an infield single off
the left heel of julio urias in the
first inning
here comes the one ball one strike pitch
[Applause]
and it's a breaking ball fisted to the
right side charged by muncie flips onto
first with
a little bit on it and gets slater 4-3
goes to put out no runs to hit a man
left
no dodger errors we go to the fourth
inning at oracle park
in san francisco dodgers nothing giants
nothing
you hit a ball well his first time up
that was caught on the warning track
max muncie out in right field the slide
and the out donovan solano
he gets it 360's into it gets up throws
a strike but the sliding 360 that's fun
here's billy mckinney
no score top of the fifth one
from logan webb to billy mckinney he is
sitting on the line right center field
baseball in the dodgers lead
billy mckinney drives in his first run
as a dodger he is
out at second but it's one-nothing
dodgers in the fifth
dodgers playing wade to pull
three infielders to the right for the
left-handed hitter
big swing and a miss and another
breaking ball as julio harris really has
the good curve tonight
and lamont wade has struck out for the
second time in the game one down in the
giant fifth
here's solano part of the one-two and
another strikeout with the elevated
fastball
and back-to-back case of wade and solano
now it's tyro estrada
up the middle and stabbed by wrist to
finish off the one two three
fifth right into david price's glove
that
julio's wearing tonight i mean that ball
was hit perfectly right back into the
webbing of julio's glove and he retires
the side in order
one two three go the giants in the fifth
will go to the sixth
dodgers one giants nothing dodgers won
giants nothing julio rius
is pitching brilliantly tonight and he
will lead off
as a hitter against logan webb who stays
in the game for the sixth
and he made short work of uria's strike
three
tackling hitting 177 overall
with the giants he struck him out with
the fastball
so now buster posey comes up in a spot
where a hit with slater's speed
to the outfield could and should tie the
game
that's a base hit
pollock's got to put a good arm but he's
way off line with a throw
cut off by bellinger and the giants have
tied the game
buster posey delivering the clutch rbi
hit
and now flores who's had some big swings
against the dodgers this year
and the fast wall is caught
a line drive caught on the right side of
the infield
so now here's billy mckinney he came up
with the runner at second
in the fifth inning and knocked him in
the only dodger run of the game
2-2 pitch ground ball past garcia right
for the shortstop estrada behind second
and he throws him out at first
inning over that runner's stranded
at second base wade solano and estrada
do up for the giants we go to the last
of the seven it's one to one
the duggar has a hit and four straight
after a three for 34 stretch
solano at second estrada is at first two
men out and the 1-0 pitch
swung on and looked toward taylor he's
got it
little soft line drive right at chris
taylor so blake trinin
needs just a couple of pitches to pour
water on the san francisco fire we go to
the eighth it's the dodgers one
giants and now the dodgers with runners
at second and third you've got the
left-handed power hitter muncie
rogers two and two pitch swinging the
ground ball to first
ruff's got it he throws home with the
runner breaking the tag and he is out at
the plate
and here is justin turner who's had a
lot of success the few times he's faced
tyler rogers
rogers at the belt he pitches
swung on a drive into deep right field
but not deep enough yaz is back he's
under it he's got it roger's always at
his best
when he's getting ground balls dodgers
got a couple of balls airborne there
but they do not score two hits
two left they had second and third and
one out with muncie and turner coming up
and tyler rogers got through it now to
the last of the eighth
posey yostremski and rough are coming up
giants won dodgers one so here comes
darren ruff
again tranning delivers
swing and the bouncer over the mount
hits softly out near second base it's
picked up by muncie he throws the first
for the out
now they've got the run down the throne
the third base is way
over the head posey had come around
third and
bellinger threw to third and he sailed
it 40
feet over the head of the third baseman
posey comes in to score
and over the third base goes yaskrimsky
and some great base running by
yostremski
in the nfl they would have penalized him
15 yards
for a throw that wide 2-1 giants an
incredible
turn of events here the first game at
first base this year for bellinger
doesn't turn out the way he'd hold so
two down and here is aj pollock
but another dangerous hitter the 1-0
pitch
swing there's a high fly ball along the
right field line
into his left yas near the line he's
under it he's got it and the giants take
game one from the dodgers